if you're doing a shirtless scene you
have to dehydrate yourself oh yeah yeah
that's the worst part of it I find out
the date okay which is the shirt off
thing and it's about a three month run
up so you've got to be in pretty good
shape but the three months before is
very specific and it finishes yeah
finishes with dehydration don't do this
at home when you're dehydrating for
three days you get to the point on the
last day where you can smell water like
nearby there's not no water for three
days on the first day you'll have a
liter and a half you increase your water
intake up to like you have about 10
liters of water it makes your skin
really thin so it sits on the muscles
you drink a lot of water a lot of water
the second day half a liter and then you
stop about 36 hours before you shoot and
then the third day no water and you'll
shoot the fourth and then put the claws
on sometimes they don't shoot the scene
till the end of the fourth day as well
and so you're the most miserable person
on the planet so yeah you know then you
have nothing in your water you die yeah
so you go as close as you can and they
go and then roll them